welcome to cs224n
um today i'm really excited that we're
going to have the first of our um guest
lectures and so tonight it's not tonight
um today
it's really great to have um martin set
so he martin is currently a young
investigator at the allen institute for
ai in seattle but pretty soon now i
guess he's going to be starting at
carnegie mellon university as a
professor um so martin's done a huge
amount of really exciting and
interesting work looking at socially
intelligent nlp systems and in
particular he's had a really strong
emphasis and looking at issues of social
inequality bias and toxicity in language
and that work's been widely noticed and
he's had it covered in the new york
times forbes fortune
etc so it'll be a great opportunity
today to hear about um some of that
interesting work that he has done okay
um oh my so notes questions martin be
delighted to have live questions um so
if you'd like to ask a live question you
can either hit the raise hand thing or
you could put in the q a you know live
queue or some
shorthand like that and then we can make
it so you can um ask live questions if
you're feeling very shy you can still
put a question in the question on so
that we can relay for you but um live
questions much preferred okay um i think
that's the only instructions and
otherwise taken away
thanks um i'll just say that there might
be a chance that i don't see the raising
hands or questions like that so if any
of the sort of coordinators can um
let me know
if there's something that's pressing i
can
you know just totally answer it as well
yeah but i will do that we'll we'll stop
you for questions
awesome yeah all right so thank you so
much for having me here today i'm really
excited um to talk about some of the
work that i've done during my phd and
that i'm currently still doing
um and today's talk is going to be
focusing specifically on work that i've
done related to detecting and rewriting
socially biased language
um and so
i want to start with a quote from uh
rita mae brown who was a feminist author
and lgbtq activist from the 60s
who said
that language is the road map of a
culture and it tells you where its
people come from and where they are
going
and so this is a known thing that many
other linguists and philosophers have
discussed that language and culture
really cannot be disentangled from each
other that much
and this is particularly interesting
when we think about understanding how
inequality or biases or hatred can
manifest themselves in language and so i
like to talk about this in a framework
that i call the cycle of social
inequality and text and so what i mean
by that is that we know that there is
social inequality between minority and
majority groups in the world for example
between men and women
and because of
how
our
language works the world is going to
influence the way that our language
patterns are different with respect to
these demographic groups and so language
is inherently going to reflect existing
social inequality
and this is going to
for example show up in the portrayals of
minority characters who
are known to be more biased or
stereotypical typically than majority
characters um and this also shows up in
the fact that for example hate speech
and toxicity are mostly going to target
minority groups and not really majority
groups
all right i'm already seeing some
discussion i think we're good um
and then in turn
um the language that uh we use or reread
is actually influencing the world itself
um and so for for example hate speech
has been shown to be able to worsen
relationships uh between uh demographic
groups
and um we also know that the portrayal
of minority characters can shape the
perceptions and stereotypes that we have
of those minority identities and so
there's this sort of cycle that happens
and so in this talk i'm going to try to
talk about how we can make nlp systems
understand and mitigate social biases
and toxicity in language and one of the
reasons um you know the crux of the
reason why this is super important is
because if any uh any human generated
data is going to inherently reflect
social dynamics and inequality and if
our nlp systems are going to be trained
on this human generated data they need
to account for
these dynamics because otherwise it can
have really harmful results
and so to drive this point home a little
bit more
um let me walk you through a couple nlp
tasks the first big task that you know
we can think about is conversational ai
and this is a very big task that people
are tackling in nlp these days you know
creating digital assistance chatbots
things like that
and you may remember the really um
awful example of microsoft's uh tay
which was an ai chat bot that they
released on twitter and it turned racist
into in less than a day um and this is
because they didn't really account for
any of the social dynamics that maybe
goes on on the internet or went into the
training data of this model um and their
bot ended up having really rude and
offensive conversations in this case
another field or subfield of nlp that
has gotten a lot of attention recently
is language generation which is similar
to conversational ai but just more about
auto completing text or continuing
stories or news articles
and here if you don't account for the
inequality or the social dynamics that
in go into your training data then you
can end up with really incoherent
mindless but also really biased or
offensive generations
and some of my own work has shown that
actually gpt 3 which is open ai's
sort of most powerful text generator out
there
really can delve into toxicity really
quickly
and then finally
also related to nlp there's this whole
field or subfield of text understanding
and particularly i've worked on things
like hate speech detection and sentiment
analysis
and here if you don't account for the
underlying dynamics that went into your
data collection your data creation you
can end up with really worse performance
on minority user input or even worse
actually bias behavior against the
minority users and so some of my own
work has actually shown that um for
example hate speech detection systems
tend to be racially biased and i'll talk
about this in a minute
um and just you know this is the deep
learning nlp class so you know we know
that in recent years there's been a lot
of improvements in nlp tests in general
thanks to these pre-trained language
models um and for the sake of this talk
i just want to highlight some of the key
parts of why this these appreciate
language models are working so well
so we know that they're large neural
nets that are trained on large amounts
of text to predict which word comes next
and they're using this thing called the
transformer architecture which is a
neural network
and so their basic recipe is to gather a
large amount of text data take a
transformer model and then train that
transformer model to predict basically a
word given its context
and you know
there's a trend of naming these models
after sesame street characters for some
reason in nlp um but we also got some uh
sort of
text generators that were named gpd2 gt3
things like that
um and we know that these models like
gpd3 are getting bigger and bigger every
day uh but also getting bigger is the
training data or the pre-training
corpora that are used to create these
language models
um and we started out with using um
quote unquote only
documents from english wikipedia or
maybe just a small set of books
all gbd2 was trained on a really large
set of documents that were basically
outbound links from reddit
and t5 and gt3 were trained on uh the
common crawl data set which is a really
large archive of basically all documents
on the internet that people could find
and here i want to pause a little bit
for a second and thinking about you know
the fact that our models are learning
language from random internet data like
what could go wrong
with that
so what could go wrong and does go wrong
is actually that these transformer
language models are really mindless and
socially oblivious
and so not only are they learning
stereotypes and social biases from their
training data
some of my own work has shown that
they're at risk for generating toxicity
really really quickly in less than 100
generations so if you sampled
a hundred sentences from gpt3 you're
likely to find something really toxic
within those hundred samples so that's
really quick and a problem
and so the crux of the issue is that as
professor rujo benjamin puts it feeding
ai systems on the world's beauty
ugliness and cruelty but expecting it to
reflect only the beauty is a fantasy
and what we need is uh formalisms to
represent and detect this um you know
ugliness and cruelty or these social
biases and algorithms to mitigate and
avoid these uh social biases and this
toxicity and this ugliness
and so
that's what i'll be talking about today
um and specifically
i'm going to talk about three projects
today the first two are going to be
about detecting toxicity and social
biases and language
and then i'll talk about
rewriting and de-biasing texts with a
model called power transformer
and then i'll talk about some exciting
future directions um that we can go in
towards human-centric social bias
detection and mitigation
so i'll start with this first work which
is called the risk of racial bias and
hate speech
detection and
this work is really tackling this
phenomenon of hate speech online
and
we know that this is a really rampant
problem that
causes people to quit social media
because there's just too much hate and
they can't take it people are treated
transgender people are reporting being
treated inhumanely um people of color
are
saying that they can't subject
themselves any longer to the hate uh you
know people are quitting and um there's
in there's um increasing calls for uh
these platforms to address this issue of
hate speech online
i'm sorry i'm just looking at the
questions more
okay
um and one of the issues with this is um
so obviously you know that platforms are
struggling to moderate this content um
and one of the issues is that it's
really challenging to rely on humans
solely to moderate this content um you
know there's
really way too many tweets or way too
many posts that are posted on these
platforms for humans to just be able to
sift through apparently according to
this source there's uh five 500 million
tweets that are sent in one day so
there's no way that we could get humans
to do this all alone
and
um you know taking sort of a
community-centric perspective like what
reddit has done where basically you
delegate the moderation to the
sub-communities that are naturally
created can lead to actually hate
endorsing communities like if you
remember
the famous case where reddit um ceo
stepped in and basically deleted or
quarantined uh several super
misogynistic subreddits um
okay i'm looking at the questions
um
are you more so someone said someone
asked are you more of a proponent for we
should only feed the model good data to
reduce toxicity or we should try to
filter model output modify what the
model has learned from the data
that is a good question um i think we
should do both because i don't there's
no way to say that something is
inherently
good and is free of biases um and
it's easier to
i mean we should be really mindful of
the data still and you know the
decisions to shoot on which data we
choose is um something that i think most
people tend to take just kind of lightly
and just take whatever's available and
we should be thinking a little bit more
about you know whose data it is are we
you know ethically using this data was
the purpose of it all this stuff but at
the same time
um
there's this issue fundamentally with
machine learning and ai and that is that
we
are trying to predict the future based
on data from the past so even if
something might not con we might not
consider something you know biased or
problematic right now maybe in a year or
two there will be sort of new evidence
that some of the stuff that we trained
stuff on was problematic so i think
having you know a stop or a way to
mitigate these uh decoding time or a
prediction time um is also
something that um we should do and i'm
actually really excited about that
direction too especially as we're
you know as we're in a new era of not
being able to train our own models with
these free train language models being
so big so
yeah i'm excited about that
hopefully that responds
to that question
um okay so i was talking about
um why you know platforms are struggling
to moderate uh this you know harmful
hateful content online and one of the
other things that is often overlooked is
that even if we ask humans to filter
through this stuff um these people that
are actually employed to do this and
stare at like you know awful awful
things all day suffer really inhumane
working conditions they're often
outsourced to countries where the
minimum wage is lower and the conditions
are just worse
and you know the mental health of these
people is just you know it's been very
documented that it's really bad
so this is a place where ai could
actually help right and so this is kind
of led to this field of automatic hate
speech detection which is all about
trying to make the internet less toxic
and there's a lot of work that has come
out of nlp trying to tackle this task
there's even a workshop on detecting
online abuses and harms um and people
are developing apis that
they can use
that you can just kind of use easily off
the shelf for example google's sister
company jigsaw develops the perspective
api which is a toxicity detection system
that is being used currently to moderate
the new york times comment section for
example
and so the first thing that i'm going to
talk about is that there's a big problem
of racial bias and hate speech detection
and when i say racial bias i'm not
talking about uh bias against racial
minorities or hate speech against racial
minorities i'm actually talking about
the kind of bias
in which a harmless greeting or harmless
tweet can be flagged as toxic when
written by certain racial minorities but
not flagged as toxic or flagged as
harmless when written by a white
maturity person
and here in this case this is happening
because our toxicity models are trained
on text-only annotations and so they
have no idea who's speaking um and
the issue specifically in this example
is that um you know the n-word spoken by
a white person is usually considered a
lot more offensive than the n-word
spoken by a black person
and so this illustrates the fact that
data sets are really underlying are
ignoring the underlying social dynamics
of speech for example the identity of
the speaker or the dialect of english
and in this case ignoring these nuances
really risks harming minority
populations by suppressing inoffensive
speech more
and so we wanted to
characterize and quantify the racial
bias in hate speech detection here
and specifically what we were wanted to
do was first investigate how machine
learning models acquire this racial bi
racial bias from data sets
and also look at sort of stepping back
thinking about the annotation task for
uh for offensiveness or toxicity and
asking what about the annotation task
design actually affects these racial
biases here
and you may be wondering why are we
looking at racial bias specifically
well the answer is that as we know
minority populations are most often the
target of hate speech compared to
majority populations
and racial bias has actually been uh
studied a lot less than other
identity-based biases and specifically
gender has gotten a lot of attention
in nlp
and specifically on twitter
there's an actual big danger of
silencing black folks disproportionately
there's been some studies that have
shown the cultural importance of twitter
specifically this phenomenon called
black twitter and it's also a really
important space for activism for example
in the black lives matter movement
however one challenge with uh studying
racial bias is that twitter profiles
don't actually have any race data
associated with them
and so
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to use dialect as a proxy for
racial identity
and we're operating under the premise
here that um there's a specific there
are specific lexical indicators of
minority identity in uh language
and specifically we're going to be
looking for african-american english
which is
um a dialect or a set of dialects or
variety of english that is common but
not limited to black or african american
folks in the u.s
and it's extensively been studied by
linguists and shown to have like its
proper its own grammar and things like
that
um and there's actually also been shown
to be presence of ae uh variants on
twitter specifically
um and so specifically we're going to
use a lexical detector that blotted it
all
created to infer the presence of aae
but again a caveat here is that you know
dialect and race are much more complex
than this
i'm seeing a question
is using dialect as proxy for racial
identity susceptible to propagating
stereotypes especially if these lexical
indicators evolve over time yeah so i
think i'm gonna click
responding to it
um
yeah so that's uh definitely
true for sure um and i'll talk about
this later as well
but you know focusing solely on dialect
again in a static way ignores the
evolution that this could have as well
as um sort of we don't want to we don't
want to categorize people's races based
on their dialect alone and that's not
what we're doing in this work we're
looking at the dialect which we know has
a correlate has correlates with
race but it's also important to look at
actually self-reported race as well uh
which i'll talk about in a second
okay so
given this intro you know let's look at
some results and look at how racially
biased our hate speech data sets
actually
um and so in this work we focused on two
widely used data sets so called twitter
hate base and twitter bootstrap which
are references to how they were
collected
and um
what we find is that there's really big
racial bias in both these data sets and
so for example in the first data set
about half of the tweets in white
aligned english which is a label that
the dialect model gives us
are
only half are flagged as offensive by
the annotators whereas 92 of them in
african-american english are flagged as
offensive so there's a huge skew and we
see a similar skew where 18 of white
aligned english in the twitter bootstrap
data set is labeled as abusive versus
much higher rates of abusive tweets that
are in african-american english
i'm seeing another question
something i noticed in a lot more online
spaces that people regrettably will use
ae despite not being black usually for
like humorous effects so i know the
system couldn't control get away with
like saying the n word by trying to put
an a spin on it
yeah that's the thing that people talk
about a lot actually um the sort of
appropriation of african-american
english or just um you know those kinds
of things and i think snl called it like
gen z slang but it really was like
markers of ae that they meant
um that's a broader question of how
language sort of gets uh you know
adopted by
different groups and and how things
evolve in that way that
i think social linguists are probably
more equipped to talk about um
but yeah it's definitely sure that like
if someone is sort of adopting an aae
identity online then they would also
maybe fall prey to this over censorship
by toxicity detection systems for sure
um oops another question reflecting on a
precision recall trade-off is
classifying and classifying such
problems
which would you do recommend approaching
model building um let me talk about the
results real quick first before we uh
talk about that so
um given that there's evidence in the
data that there's a lot of racial bias
like we wanted to see
how you know do models actually acquire
these racial biases from data sets and
maybe you're thinking oh god maybe
they're actually averaging those out
because they learn to pick out the right
patterns of the data right because
models can do that and we're really
optimistic about it
um unfortunately models actually not
only acquire these racial biases but
they exacerbate them so that's a problem
and in order to show this um we
basically trained classifiers on two on
these two data sets that we were looking
at hate base and bootstrap
and we're going to look at rates of
false flagging of toxicity and
specifically
we're going to break those false
flagging of toxicity rates down by a
dialect group on our development set
and here this is and we're going to look
for bias under the definition of the
equality of odds opportunity criterion
from moore's heart
and
looking at the results here what we find
is that
both data sets are really biased against
ae and specifically they make mistakes
towards mistaken ae as offensive much
more often than a mistake in white
online english so the first one uh 46 of
non-offensive aae tweets are mistaken
for offensive versus only nine percent
of white uh non-offensive tweets
and in the second classifier data set 26
percent of non-abusive ae tweets are
mistaken for abusive versus only five
percent white uh and the opposite is
true for the second data set where white
tweets will that are actually abusive
are flagged as non-abusive at a much
higher rate
um okay does does that answer your
question i don't know if that's what you
were specifically asking about but um
would you recommend approach to model
building
yeah so i think in this case maybe the
question will be answered uh later about
you know
actually instead of thinking about model
building we should be thinking about
different ways to uh conceptualize this
task
um
okay how do we distinguish between
disproportionate hate speech detection
due to true positive false positive
um hopefully that
those results just answered your
question here
do you think asking users for more
personal details as race is too much of
a risk for users privacy
that's an interesting ethical question
um i think unfortunately if we want to
do
research that involves people like we
need volunteers and we need people to
give us information because um i think
we have enough evidence that without um
actually
you know studying these problems and
tackling and like really digging into
the issues related to identity um we're
not really gonna be able to make
something less biased unfortunately
um okay let me move on for a second
before i answer some more questions but
um so you know what we've seen here in
the sort of in domain and distribution
setting is that there's really strong
bias against ae tweets for both these
classifiers and both these data sets
but
um you may be wondering okay maybe this
is a data set problem and the racial
bias doesn't really generalize beyond
these data sets right unfortunately it
really does
and so this is kind of addressing this
question that i just answered about race
and asking people their race um
so in order to simulate we wanted to
stimulate a situation where these
classifiers would be like released in
the wild
and we looked basically at prediction
rates of offensiveness when you actually
have like more gold standard dialect uh
or race information available
um and specifically we looked at one
corpus that had dialects inferred based
on geolocation of tweets and u.s census
demographic data so it's not gold it's
maybe silver uh
silver standard labels
um but sort of more informed by like
where the tweet came from so the dialect
might be the dialogue label might be a
little bit more valid
um and what we find is that the our one
of our classifiers basically has twice
is twice as likely to predict that an a
tweet is offensive compared to a white
aligned tweet
and then we also looked at another data
set where um people actually um you know
participated in a survey online gave uh
researchers their race as well as a
twitter handle and they give a bunch of
other demographics too um and those uh
researchers then uh sort of scraped all
their tweets and to study uh i don't
remember what the purpose of this study
was specifically online uh but we can
use this data set to actually see you
know regardless of dialect like what is
actually happening when when we look at
self-reported race and what we find
unfortunately is the same kind of biases
that are there in dialect land um and
you know the classifier here is 1.5
times as likely to flag a tweet by an
african-american person as offensive
compared to a tweet by a white person
and unfortunately this is basically the
exact same pattern in the second uh
classifier that we studied um
where you know basically this is showing
that not just a e tweets but also tweets
by black folks are more often flagged as
toxic compared to uh tweets by white
people or in white alliance english
and this is really strong evidence that
this racial bias is really generalizing
to other corpora here
um
let me take a minute here to answer some
questions
okay
in the past there are cases where
companies saying that their model is
biased because the data is biased but it
seems impossible to have perfect data it
just seems that right now we have no one
talking taking direct responsibility on
the bias toxic problematic models
do you think there's a practical way to
address this and in your opinion should
the burdens fall on researchers working
in the area of bias detection all nlp
researchers or companies that use apply
the models or the society where the data
comes from
um
this is a very
astute question um let me think about
this for a second
so i think one thing that we forget with
these systems is that
ai
isn't just operating in a vacuum it's
operating um in a full societal pipeline
between users and government and like
laws and companies and stuff
and so a lot of times
you know researchers are like oh well i
don't really know you know i don't i'm
sort of turning a blind eye to how my my
systems are being used um but like in
order to really address like fair and
equitable
like i'm just going to use this example
of like toxic content detection
like it does require like you know rules
and laws and sort of
a full pipeline uh you know involvement
for for tackling this
so um
it's not necessarily like
yeah maybe the people the companies that
are applying these models are the ones
that should be held responsible i'm not
really sure in terms of that like where
where the responsibility should lie but
i think that we should have um you know
operating under the premise of a
democratic government we should have um
you know legislation that actually
dictates like what can and can't be
suppressed or removed through
um
through these algorithms and i think
currently the situation is that the
companies have all the power to do
whatever they want um and i think that's
led to a lot of frustration from a lot
of people um and so the answer might be
that you know other companies that are
you know more inclusivity uh designed
with inclusivity from the gecko could be
a solution there um but yeah this is a
probably a longer question uh to to
answer directly
there's a live question so let's have a
second go and see if we can get someone
to ask one live
can you hear me yeah
okay wonderful yeah i'm wondering of
course um i don't know if
these models have um are
um
open about how they operationalize the
term toxic or hate speech but i'm
curious if you have any insight into
that because that seems like um not only
do you have the issue of you know making
the model accurate um based on your um
rule set but also defining a rule set
because um different people like the
naacp would say that the n word is never
acceptable other people um other black
people may feel differently um so it
seems that there's also a um
even within that model um
a level of interpretation
yeah for sure um i
i totally agree and i think that
um
again like kind of pointing forward to
the rest of this talk like i i always
advocate for like just not having ai
systems determine offensiveness period
and just moving towards like other
approaches to doing this kind of
problems
um
so
yeah let me
keep going a little bit and maybe answer
some questions after that if that's okay
um
okay so we know that there's a lot of
racial bias in these classifiers and it
just seems really bleak
so
you know you probably are all wondering
like okay
what can we actually do to reduce these
biases
um one answer is that actually changing
the way that we do data collection helps
um and so to test this out we did a
small sort of emter pilot study where we
took 350 ae tweets from our two data
sets stratified by toxicity label um and
we asked um three annotators to look at
each tweet um and specifically we wanted
them to answer a question about how
or whether could this tweet could be
offensive to anyone
and um we did uh sort of
abc testing basically where we had three
conditions in which people were labeling
these the first one the control
condition was them so annotating just
the text of the tweet no context no
nothing
the second condition um where
we basically provided them with
information about the dialect of the
tweet so we were like oh rai thinks that
this tweet is in african american
english
basically highlighting the fact that
this may come from a user who was
speaking african-american english and we
see here that there's actually a
significant decrease
in the likelihood of labeling these
tweets as offensive to anyone which is
really interesting
and then a second or the third condition
that we had was basically instead of
thinking about the dialect we made
people think about the race that is
associated with the dialect and so um
our priming text was basically like a
twitter user that is likely black or
african american tweeted
this thing
and here again we see a significant
difference based on compared to the
controlled condition
we also asked the second question of
offensiveness which is is this tweet
offensive to you which is a different
sort of
labeling
and one of the interesting things here
is that the labeling the the propensity
for people to label a tweet as offensive
to anyone is much higher than uh labeled
offensive to them
or to themselves
um and also here uh we found that the
only difference in decreasing sort of
offensiveness of themselves is if we
highlighted the race uh associated with
the dialect and not just the dialect
itself compared to the control condition
so this shows that you know priming
annotators to think about dialect and
race can actually influence the labels
and maybe mitigate some of this bias
but also just even using two questions
we can show that the annotations of
offensiveness are highly subjective like
the mental processes that the labelers
are going through are
very different
um so to quickly give some takeaways uh
of this work
overtakes the city really backfires
against racial minorities if we try to
automate it
and we showed specifically that there's
really strong dialect-based racial bias
um likely do we hypothesize that this is
probably due to like the negative
perception of race and ae it's just
thought sometimes thought of as like
less good english or things like that
um and you know nlp models will
that are trained on this bias data will
just exacerbate those biases
and in our pilot study we showed that um
highlighting the dialect can actually
influence the labels of offensiveness
but kind of tackling some of the themes
that have been in the question so far
like maybe you know given this situation
we should rethink how we tackle hate
speech detection as a whole
um and to hammer this point even
to him around this point even more
racial bias isn't the only
bias or issue that is going on in
toxicity classification systems there's
also this thing that we like to call
lexical biases
which is basically that if you have a
minority identity um you'll
your system is likely to flag it as
toxic uh more likely to flag it as toxic
compared to if you uh have a majority
identity in your text
um there's also bias against swear words
so like if you say something positive
like i [ __ ] love this um your model
is going to flag it as super toxic but
if you say something that's really awful
but doesn't have any swear words your
model might just not even realize that
it's a problem
um and just to highlight this a little
bit so in some recent work that we
presented at eacl
we actually tried to see if we could
automatically de-bias the racial biases
and lexical biases in toxicity language
detection models
and specifically we asked can automatic
de-biasing methods from nli you know
natural language inference tasks
mitigate these biases because there's
been a lot of work in devicing and align
systems
for example there's been things looking
into ensemble model learning as well as
data filtering and things like that
and i encourage you to read the paper
but the answer the short answer is that
it's not that easy to de-bias these
models actually and um
it's easier to de-bias if your bias or
biases are lexical so like related to
keywords but um it's actually a lot
harder for dialect-based biases to be
removed or mitigated in these systems
i'm quite martin uh there is a question
awesome hi martin um i
hello uh i'm wondering so for the
different types of priming for dialect
and race priming um i'm wondering
because they seem quite similar to me
um in terms of like they're in terms of
conceptually as like part of the
experiment so
um
also like the the results seem to be
pretty similar between them so what is
the significance of having both the
dialect and the race because shouldn't
one kind of entail the other
yeah so i mean it's kind of going back
to like the question of like not
everyone who is black speaks a e and not
everyone who's a is black who speaks a
is black um and also just in terms of
lay people's uh knowledge of aae like i
think most people in america know what a
black person is but i don't think that
you know maybe maybe 60 70 i don't know
how that's maybe too high um you know i
don't know how many people actually know
what african-american english is and or
consider it like um you know a valid
form of language and so when we're
thinking about these annotation tasks
like we should think about also like who
what is the knowledge that these
annotators have and so when we were
doing the dialect priming condition we
gave them information about the dialects
but in the race in the race condition
the race priming condition we didn't
have to give them that much information
because people know what um you know
race is broadly
so that's kind of the difference
okay yeah thank you that makes a lot
more sense thank you sure
um
i wanted to
should i answer some more questions or
what do we think
how many years are we away from a time
where we may not need an army of human
moderators for explicit content um i
would advocate that we should never be
free of human moderators i think that
letting ai systems
you know remove or moderate things
automatically
is not the greatest option because
that gives them power to silence us in a
way that we don't want that
um
does the race ethnicity of the annotated
matter in these data sets since we are
using these graph truth labels how do we
show the correctness of label quality
with perspective of different races um
thank you so much for a great segue into
my next slide which is talking about
who decides what is offensive or not um
and so i want a quick plug for our
recent pre-print that came out in
november called annotators with
attitudes how annotated beliefs and
identities bias toxic language detection
and basically what we studied in this
work is uh literally what you just asked
about which is uh the who why and what
behind toxicity annotation so basically
looking at uh what is the effect of
annotator identities and beliefs
on their toxicity labeling behavior as
well as uh looking at what types of text
they're likely to label as toxic more or
not
and specifically we did two controlled
annotation studies where we collected
attitudes about different concepts like
offensiveness um or we asked them about
like sort of racism we asked them about
free speech we asked them about empathy
and things like that and we also
collected their demographic information
and um some things that are uh showing
up is that um
racist texts so things that are really
racist in meaning
are less likely to be labeled as
offensive by people who already hold
racist beliefs
also less likely to be labeled as
offensive by people who
don't think that censorship should exist
for example
i don't fully remember what the
demographic correlates are but i'm going
to
assume maybe for racist speech there
wasn't that much of a difference
but uh we also found that
african-american english tweets seem
more racist to people who hold racist
beliefs which is also a really
interesting finding there um
and then finally uh we looked at sort of
the swear word piece of it as well and
what we found was that swear words can
seem much more offensive to people who
are more conservative uh so politically
conservative as well as more traditional
er rated as um
the
as like as
using a psychological traditionalism
scale
um
should i be following up on the
discussion and the q and a or um
i'm looking at i mean i guess you have
to judge
how many questions you can answer and
how much you want to make progress
welcome to answer more yeah i mean yeah
um i think i could answer a couple
questions
are these models learning toxicity tweet
entries other corporates that are
labeled a priori or of any supervised
learning or any core
i'm not sure i fully understand this
question
um
does identity of researchers influence
how data sets are created and what's
considered toxic since the mainstream
view by the construction reflects the
majority demographic
um
that's an interesting question of like
what's what about the positionality of
the researchers themselves
um
i think
typically probably that influences
things uh but i think to sort of
keep going with my talk here like i
think that really we should be
rethinking automatic offensiveness
detection totally
um
and
you know just to really recap everything
like we know that there's a lot of
labeling variation um in these things
like what what is offensiveness to whom
like it's really different depending on
your background your attitudes and
everything um
and you know even just the task phrasing
can make a big difference but also when
we think about hate speech like there's
some countries that actually have like
legal definitions of hate speech right
and so we can't just go throwing around
that term being like this is hate speech
when there's like legal definitions of
this and legal implications of labeling
something is hate speech um and then you
know like the question asked like you
know looking at the fact that annotators
might operationalize a definition
differently uh nlp researchers might
have different views of what you know
should go on in there
and i think that one big component is
that you know
no one's asking the real question of
like why is something hateful or
offensive like everyone's just like
concerned with labeling and noise and
annotations but like why aren't we
focusing on like what about the text is
like making it offensive or hateful
and also just to hammer this point home
that i've already mentioned like i don't
think that um you know personally my
position is that we don't we should we
really have ai systems making these
decisions alone like risking removing
entire swaths of dialects uh uh you know
of content
in you know moderating that like i'm not
sure that that's really what should be
going on
so what if um ai systems were designed
to help humans determine toxicity by
explaining why something might be toxic
or biased instead
and um this is going to be the next part
of my talk but let me look at some
questions real quick
okay for the bias evaluation the genesis
must have re-annotated to not classify a
tweets using
as much as the n word is not offensive
if models were trained on this three
annotated data set does that mitigate
the issue in other words when the nlp
models know that the n-word is only
offensive in non-ae dialects
yeah so we actually did um in the
challenges in automatic devicing paper
we did do a a translation experiment uh
where we basically tried to translate
the ae tweets into like non-ae english
um and that was like the most promising
direction basically when you sort of
like remove the markers of ae but try to
preserve as much of the content um and
sort of
um use those labels there but then the
issue is that you have to relabel those
um
to uh you have to re-label those in sort
of a context of
their non-ae versions so that sort of
adds data to the or data annotation to
the challenge
um
it seems like a lot of the classifiers
right now are very lexically focused is
there a way to make the model more
contextually aware
um yes and i think that's something that
we should be focusing on more and more
and i'll talk about that in some future
work
uh so these are the models picking up on
raw tokens such as swear words would you
go without it if i just said let's talk
about yes so that's kind of also what
i'm going to talk about in this next
part
um
i think i'm trying to like
take care of these questions let me
rephrase my question how are talks is
how are these toxicity classifying
algorithms learning what is it is it
toxic based on labels right and that's
kind of the issue is like if the humans
are labeling things improperly because
they're flagging just words then the
models are just only going to be able to
um recreate that behavior um
i do see
i hope that there's going to be
potential regulations coming up towards
this kind of
you know regulating what ai systems can
and can't do but that also requires like
tackling the fact that tech companies
have a lot more
freedom in the us right now
um
okay
is it possible that developing a model
that detects a person's identity through
this tweets has some potential privacy
issue how to mitigate the potential
harmful use yeah so i think that um
language unfortunately kind of is a way
to communicate your identity to people
um and so like that's what social
linguists talk about when you sort of do
code switching between your family and
your work friends um like you are sort
of asserting a common shared identity or
creating a common shared identity
between your family and you in that one
uh sort of dialect or way of speaking um
and if you're speaking to your
co-workers maybe you're gonna use a
different type of way of speaking
and so
like sure maybe like no one should be
you know spying on you and looking at
like oh you're speaking to a co-worker
versus not but if people are tweeting in
these uh settings then
um they're giving away a little bit of
like who they're tweeting to
and things like that so um
yeah when it comes to like studying
these kinds of things it's hard to it's
hard to disentangle um
you know it's or it's hard to do without
knowing actually like who the identities
of the people are in the network but um
it's it's just not as simple as as
sort of like your behavioral patterns
might not give away as much of your
identity markers as language can
all right i think i'm gonna
walk through some more slides a little
bit first and then we can look at the
questions some more but if there's
anything really important please let me
know
all right so we talked about the
problems with um you know
classifying toxicity
or toxic language
so i want to talk about social bias
frames which is actually a
um
like what i would like to call like a
new alternative way of looking at this
problem or you know
the first iteration of that
so social advice frames is a new
formalism to reason about the social and
power implications of language
and i know that we've been talking about
hate speech and stuff like that already
but i want to warn you that the content
in this uh the rest of this talk may be
upsetting or offensive because i'm going
to show some examples unfortunately um
and again just to contextualize this a
little bit more um we are approaching
these problems of social diocese from a
u.s social cultural perspective in this
uh in this project and this is actually
work with um another step for professor
genjarovsky
okay so when we think about social
biases there's a two ways that um these
social biases can be expressed in
language um first one is we should kill
all xyz demographic group um and this is
super easily flagged as toxic by your
off-the-shelf toxicity detection systems
but there's a much more subtle way of
expressing social biases for example in
the statement we should lower our
standards just to hire more women
and so we can all
here understand that this type of
unconscious bias here um this because of
how language implicature works like this
is implying that
women are less qualified than men
especially because this just word here
is really hammering that
and so we can understand that this is an
unconscious bias but it's not flagged as
toxic at all by these models
unfortunately
and so this motivated our creation of
social bias frames as a new structured
formalism that distills knowledge about
the harmful or biased implications of
language
and so specifically this is kind of a
structured formalism so let me walk you
through the structure um so if we have a
post we should lower our standards just
to hire our women
we're going to ask um annotators like is
this offensive or not as a sort of
pre-screening round we're going to look
at was this you know do you think this
was intended to be offensive or not in
this case maybe
um we're going to ask
is this a lewd statement or referencing
something sexual not really here
if it was annotated as offensive we're
going to look at is this targeting a
group of people or referencing a group
of people or is this
really just an individual insult
if it is a group of people we're going
to ask for a free text explanation of
who that group of people was in this
case it's women and then we're going to
ask for a free text explanation of
what is the implied stereotype here and
this is the stereotype that women are
less qualified than men
and then finally the last variable in
our frame is
related to in-group language which is
about sort of capturing whether the
statement is made by members of the same
group as the group that's targeted um
kind of
trying to address this sort of uh you
know speaker and listener identities
but here in this case that doesn't
really seem to be the case
so again to remind you the motivation
for social bias frames is really that if
we want to be able to avoid like
problematic or
really if companies want to avoid pr
problems uh of their chatbots turning
racist um they need an understanding of
what they actually want to avoid and
social buy streams is a new view on this
what to avoid or these social biases
and it's more explainable and
trustworthy because it comes baked in
with explanations of like why something
could be biased
and it's more holistic than binary hate
speech detection because um it gets
around like are you uh you know offended
by this statement or not i'm really it's
trying to distill like what is the uh
what is the offensive meaning behind
this which is different
um i also want to highlight that um you
know in order to study these social
biases in the wild we created the social
vice inference corpus which is 150 000
uh annotated tuples um that were um
labeled from 4 4 000 uh posts from
social media including from twitter um
reddit uh the neo-nazi communities of
like gab and stormfront
as well as some banned uh really
misogynistic subreddits
um and our corpus contains like 34 000
implications about about three um
three thousand different demographic
groups
um and i don't have time to go into the
details of how this was created but um
because of how we um trained our m
turkers and our annotators and how we
selected them we actually got pretty
high pairwise agreement on this on you
know these annotations and also um we
really wanted to be able to capture
the types of discrimination that people
are actually reporting experiencing
offline or you know or online but in the
real world um and so we're not just
capturing like uh
sort of fandom wars uh or pops our
fandom wars but we're actually capturing
like hatred towards demographic groups
that are reflective of real world
discrimination
also i wanted to highlight um the way
that we designed this frame inherently
had interdisciplinary sort of um
knowledge in mind and so we really tried
to ground this in social science
literature specifically looking at
literature of rudeness pragmatics
offensiveness and how people sort of
perceive offensiveness and things like
that and this actually led to the
inclusion of this intent variable which
is um not only there because
if you sort of perceive someone as being
well intentioned you might be more
forgiving towards what they're saying uh
even though you know their bias is still
there um but also if we think about
implementing these tools to give
feedback to people who are writing texts
and if you if your ai system tells you
this is 80 toxic versus hey you might
have not like intended to be offensive
but here's like what your thing implies
about this group of people um that could
actually be a much softer feedback to an
author
um also you know as as we've discussed
with the ae racial bias case like we
wanted to include situations where um
things were
things were cases of language that's
more in-group um so that's things like
self-deprecation or reclaimed slurs that
can appear offensive if you're not
member of a group but if you are a
member it could be less offensive
um and then we also wanted to be a
little more intersectional so we wanted
to have
the ability for posts to target multiple
groups at the same time or multiple
identities and so we collected that and
we also collected multiple implications
to get more uh data for the kinds of
stereotypes that are there
and then finally we you know the way
that we design this frame also had in
mind the
sort of annotators to see like what can
and can be done at scale
i see a question
how accurately can ai detect intent from
text if at all i will answer that in a
second because we're going to look at
some results
what about ae or models finding
offensive is it mainly used to the
n-word um actually if you go sorry this
was a question for before but if you go
to the appendix of the racial bias paper
we have like the most common features
that are used um by the classifier to
determine things and plotted by
likelihood of aae um you should take a
look at that and it will answer that so
it's not just the n word but it also is
like suffixes that appear in words and
things like that
um
okay i think the other two are like
maybe a little bit longer so i'm gonna
answer them later
um okay so given that we have a corpus
as annotated with social bias frames we
wanted to know like how good are nlp
models actually making inferences using
uh social bias frames and so we set up a
case study
uh where the goal is to predict an
entire social bias frame from a
previously unseen post
and in order to do this our model
requires classifying these categorical
variables of like intent and
offensiveness and things like that but
also it needs to be able to generate the
groups and implied statements
so not all models are able to do this
but uh gpt style models actually can't
do this if we set them up correctly um
and so the way that we did this is um we
took our social bias frame and there's
some cool animations to watch out um and
we linearized it adding special tokens
for each classification variable
um and then we passed them through a
transformer based conditional language
model that we had initialized with gpd2
in this case
and then we optimized the negative log
likelihood of all tokens
for training
and then for predicting social bias
frames
we are going to frame this as like a
conditional generation setting of the
linearized frame uh token by tokens sort
of sampling it
but
can anyone tell me if there's anything
wrong with the generated frame right
here
so actually you know there's a big
problem here that the post was predicted
not to be offensive but still having
implications about black folks
and this is a problem here where
generated frames cannot can sometimes
not be consistent with the frame
structure
and this is because when you linearize
your model can sometimes just not learn
this whole structure properly
and so what we need to do is enforce the
structure post hoc and so um i'm going
to gloss over the details here but
basically you can either just kind of
like top down and force it or we can do
something a little bit more global and
let your
future decisions correct your past
mistakes a little bit and we see a
little bit of difference that this
constrained to sort of more holistic
inference helps
but sort of answering the question of
like how well can models you know how
well do models do at these different
classification variables um
well it's maybe okay to predict whether
something was like intended to be
offensive or not um but what is really
much more challenging is predicting
whether something is targeting a group
or an individual as well as um
predicting whether something is in group
languages this is really hard to do
especially given the data that we have
um but more interestingly like the
performance of how models are able to
generate the implications is actually uh
interesting to look at
and
i'm going to gloss over the automatic
sort of metrics of this here
but the model is able to identify the
right targeted group like actually
pretty well
but the bias implications are a lot more
challenging to generate
which
i can illustrate with an example
um after answering some more questions
because i'm seeing things pop up
posts from fandom
twitter might be overly offensive for
comedic effect ethically should be
concerned about these types of posts
yeah so that's one of the reasons why i
think it's important to think about like
who's being offended or like what is the
implication here
um and like i'm a big believer that we
should tackle like
important problems sorry twitter uh but
like um
people aren't dying or being like killed
because they're a selena gomez fan uh
however people are dying because they're
you know a trans woman like that is you
know one of the highest murder rates in
the country so
trans women of color specifically so
like that's the kind of biases that i
think rei systems should tackle and like
capturing arguments between political
parties online like isn't that important
uh in my view but um that's why and you
know but this type of
these type of informations of like who's
actually being targeted like who's being
harmed that wasn't there until social
bias frames appeared like no one thought
about this kind of stuff um before they
were just like oh this is offensive or
not and so you end up just putting the
same you know you know anti-semitism in
the same bucket as like anti some pop
stars fandom
sort of arguments so i think that's a
really good
um point um
how are the free text responses
processed in the model um so it's
literally just token by token so it's
kind of like language modeling
conditional language modeling um i maybe
would refer you to the paper for a
little bit more detail but it's like
really just word by word
why is a generative method you subject
to the frames rather than a
classification model so we have to
generate the implications like those are
literally just like open-ended strings
um so we can't just use classification
and we could just do separate like you
know classification first and then add a
different model but that would just
um i mean i encourage you to try if you
want to um but that may work about the
same potentially
okay so let's look at some examples um
again so warning there's some offensive
content here
all right so here's an example from the
dev set of social bias inference corpus
that says i love gay guys they're so
much fun i would love to have a gay guy
best friend but lesbians are just
annoying
so the model here predicts that this
post is offensive because um it implies
that lesbians are annoying which is
basically just written there
um
and this is in line with what the
annotators wrote which is that um this
post
implies that lesbians are annoying but
the annotators also wrote that this post
implies that all gay guys are fun to be
around
and so um this illustrates the kind of
mistakes that this model tends to make
which is that it can typically be
successful when there's really verbatim
cues
but
they struggle with more subtle biases
for example the positive stereotype that
all gay guys are fun to be around um and
social psychologists tell us that these
positive positive stereotypes can have
also nefarious effects on people um even
though they're not negative in sentiment
another example here um is
about a black guy who's in class and
throws a paper ball into the trash and
his teacher says that he's a disgrace to
his race
the model here predicts that this post
implies that
black people are trash which is not what
the annotators wrote and in fact the
annotators here correctly flagged that
um this post implies that black men are
defined by their athletic skill or that
all black men should be good at
basketball
and again this is an example of where a
model might be relying on negative
keywords for and finding the identity
based words as well as the negative
keywords and just combining them and
assuming that that's what the
implication is and so
um this kind of keyword based reliance
is not
you know uh is not uh
sort of only specific to this task like
there's a lot of places where models
tend to rely on lexical cues a lot more
um but
yeah so we need some new modeling
advances to do this task better probably
so um just to summarize this real quick
so social bias frames is a new formalism
to distill the harmful or biased
implications of language
we introduced the new data set with
annotations and then
our experiments show that models really
struggle with these more subtle biased
implications which motivates as i said
the need for better structured reasoning
about social biases and people and
groups in language
so at a higher level though
the goal of social bias frames was
basically to create an interpretable or
explainable formalism that could um
represent social biases and language
and these explanations can be really
useful for determining you know what's
already uh what's what's going on in
already written text so for example i'm
imagining social bias frames as being
helpful um for helping content
moderators make decisions so not just
having the text but also having like the
implications if our models were good you
know having implications of the posts be
associated with there and people could
have uh make me a more uh informed
decision about moderation
um it could also be really useful if
you're sort of looking at like a corpus
of data that you're interested in
quantifying like you know how much
sexism is appearing in this corpus and
you can sort of do that with these kinds
of explanations
but
what i'm really excited about too is
that these explanations could actually
help authors as they are writing text by
pointing out the maybe unintentional
biases in their text
and so this opens the door for devising
text through rewriting
which is the next part of this talk that
i'm going to talk about in the final
project but
i will answer one more question real
quick this is not a technical question
but i tried to develop models to filter
out offensive content but i had to give
up because it was mentally exhausting to
see the offensive content myself yes
what do you think is the best way to
protect the researcher and annotators
themselves from
the effect of harmful target data set
during research could you share any
personal tips
so
i think that um personally i am just
kind of
used to staring at this data now um so i
may be a little bit
less affected by it because i think that
um
there's something empowering about
knowing that i'm doing something about
the issue so that makes me a little bit
less
sort of affected by it when it comes to
annotators i always
you know i think i always try to align
their motivations with the same goal you
know like we're trying to make the
internet less toxic like really trying
to make a difference here and that's why
we're doing this we're not just you know
displaying these awful things to you for
you know a fun purpose um
also like try to take breaks
um i also have you know extended
experience being in therapy so that
helps uh you know having support system
and things like that just really not
approaching this from a place where um
you're already vulnerable but if you can
sort of
have a support system and take breaks
and things like that that makes it a lot
easier to do this kind of research
but like i said i think there's
something just like kind of empowering
about knowing that i'm you know trying
to tackle an important problem
okay so let me talk about this last part
of the talk which is uh power
transformer um
and so power transformer is an
unsupervised controllable revision model
for biased language correction
and what i mean when i say biased
language correction here is we're
looking at bias through the lens of
connotation frames of power and agency
so what these words mean is um basically
connotation frames of power and agency
were are a common sense formalism that
um i introduced in 2017 with my
co-authors
and it distills knowledge or
connotational knowledge related to verbs
or verb predicates
um and specifically so for example if
you have
someone is pursuing something
this connotation frame is going to
distill knowledge about the power
differential between the agent and the
theme of the verb so the object and the
subject of the verb
so in this case when someone is pursuing
something it's kind of likely that the
person doing the pursuing has less power
than the person that they're trying to
pursue but they're not able to get
um
also the connotation frames capture
notions of agency that is attributed to
the person doing the action or the event
and so in this case someone who's high
agency is someone who tends to be very
decisive active driving change so
someone who is pursuing something is
like really driving that change of like
pursuing the thing but also someone
who's wiping beating fighting shooting
scarring things like that
versus someone who's low agency tends to
be very passive and experiencing uh
events so that's maybe someone who's
doing more tripping on things or
sleeping or viewing or dozing or
dreaming things like that
and so we can actually use these
connotation frames to analyze um all
sorts of texts and specifically in this
original work in 2017 we analyzed the
way that characters were portrayed in
movie scripts
modern movie scripts i should say
and we wanted to study basically the
agency levels of characters with respect
to their gender
um and so
just glossing over the details here but
what we found is that in these modern
movie scripts men were portrayed with
much higher agency and women were
portrayed with much lower agency
unfortunately
and again this is an example of
what i you know called a cycle of social
inequality in text because in the world
men um unfortunately have more societal
and decision-making power than women
and this in turn then you know
transforms it and when we're writing
texts we tend to portray women as less
agentic and more powerful than men
because it's just kind of how the world
works
and so then when we read these texts
this reinforces our perceptions of
gender roles and stereotypes and
could just continue this cycle
but this motivated our new task of
controllable de-biasing which basically
is asking can machines learn to revise
text to de-bias these portrayals and
essentially break the cycle of social
inequality in text
and so specifically the goal of
controllable debian of our story
sentences is to take in a sentence like
mayday dreams of being a doctor where uh
may is portrayed in you know very
passively with low agency
and we're going to rewrite it to may
pursues her dream to be a doctor where
may all of a sudden has a much higher
agency uh than before
so there's actually two challenges to
doing this kind of thing um the first
one is that contrary to some existing
sort of work on uh rewriting we cannot
just paraphrase the sentences because a
lot of times the biases are actually
um
not just in the framing of the actions
that are attributed to characters but
actually in the actions themselves
um
and so on the other hand we also want to
avoid making unnecessary meaning changes
and completely rewriting the sentence so
we want to preserve as much of the
meaning as we can while also still
de-biasing
and so what you want is targeted edits
with minimal meaning change
a second challenge is that this is
essentially an unsupervised task um and
what i mean by that is that there's no
parallel input output pairs that can
show a model like this is exactly what
you should rewrite this sentence to um
and so the way that people have tackled
this problem before is using generator
discriminator models by uh basically
setting up like uh you know
discriminated on top of your generation
model and kind of like gans style things
um
but
oftentimes research has shown that this
leads to really you know disfluent or
less grammatical output text
and so our approach is um we're gonna
you follow leonal's approach of masking
and reconstructing sentences
um but in order to really do this fully
we have to add two novel modeling
aspects to this um the first one is we
added an additional paraphrasing
training objective and then at um
testing time or at generation time we're
going to add a vocabulary boosting
mechanism to reach the desired agency
levels better
all right so let me walk you through the
way that power transformer is set up
so the way this model works is we start
with an input sentence um like may
daydreams of being a doctor and a
desired agency level in this case like
high agency
um we're gonna mask all the agency
markers from the input sentence using
our connotation frames
we're going to transform our desired
agency level into a special token
we're going to feed those into a
transformer based conditional language
model in this case initializes gpt and
then at training time we're going to use
our joint reconstruction and
paraphrasing objective and then at test
time or generation time we're going to
use our vocab boosting mechanism on top
of the probabilities that are given to
us by the model
to even further reach the desired agency
level
so to be a little bit more specific the
joint training objective has two parts
the first one is an
in-domain reconstruction objective which
takes in sentences from our story corpus
uh masks the agency markers and then
optimizes the log likelihood of the
reconstructed sentence
and then the second one is an out of
domain paraphrasing objective which
basically uses pairs of paraphrases from
tv subtitles so very different corpus uh
very different domain and then optimizes
the likelihood of a sentence given its
mass paraphrase
and then the way that our decoding time
uh that our vocab boosting mechanism
works is essentially it's going to
increase the likelihood of tokens that
are connoting the right desired agency
levels
and we're doing that by adding a vocab
size vector
to um for the right agency levels at
each decoding time step
so basically like every time we generate
a new word we're going to shift the
probabilities up of the words that are
kind of in the right direction of the
right agency
um and then we can do this shifting at
different strengths using a parameter
beta here
um so there's a lot of different
components in this model right so we can
actually wanted to measure whether you
know all these components actually
mattered um and uh just doing some
ablation studies where we looked at
whether you know the vocab boosting
actually helped or reconstruction or the
joint objective and things like that we
actually do find a performance gain from
both the vocab boosting and the joint
objective looking at whether or not we
reach the desired agency levels such as
in terms of accuracy
but this is a kind of open-ended
generation task uh where we have an
input sentence and an output sentence
that could look like a lot of things um
and so
we don't really have good automatic ways
of evaluating this kind of open-ended
generation task unfortunately is today
it's really still an open problem if
you're excited about you know evaluating
text generation i encourage you to work
on it because it's really exciting um
but unfortunately until we have a really
good text evaluation assess the system
um we tend to rely on human evaluations
instead to tell us like how good these
outputs are
and so that's what we did in this paper
we designed a head-to-head evaluation
task where we basically gave
the raiders the output of two systems
and then asked them which one better
preserve the meaning and which one
better preserved the agency compared to
the original sentence
um and we actually compared our um
full power transformer models outputs to
the non-boosted version of the model as
well as two bass lines from related
tasks but different tasks
and what we find is that uh the both
power transformer models actually are
better at preserving the meaning than
the previous bass lines
um and then the full power transformer
model with the vocab boosting actually
has more accurate output agency levels
compared to
the other baselines
so given that we have evidence that our
model actually works well
we want in this paper in this project to
circle back to the movies uh scripts
that i mentioned earlier and then see
how power transformer can help actually
uh sort of mitigate these biases
so as you recall in the original movie
scripts um we found that men were
portrayed with higher positive agents
than women
um and so we're going to do a case study
where we're going to rewrite the lines
that describe female characters using
power transformer specifically trying to
give these characters more agency
um and so in the revised scripts what we
find is that not only do women have a
much higher agency than before
but um if we compare the gender effects
actually um
all of a sudden women have much higher
agency than male characters
statistically significantly so
so
these coefficients look really big and i
want to sort of give a caveat here that
this is a very broad swath approach to
de-biasing language
because we rewrote every single
character that uh was detected as being
female
but i think here what this actually
illustrates is the promise for using
human ai collaborative writing setups to
help people maybe write less
stereotypically so kind of enhancing
this writing uh
sort of
platforms or these tools that people are
using to write to give them more
information about how what they write
might be perceived
so um you know glossing over the
contributions of power transformer here
we introduced the new task of
controllable devising i talked about
these connotation frames which are a new
common sense formalism um and then
introduced a new model power transformer
and we showed in the case study that we
could actually mitigate automatically
mitigate some of the gender biases in
movie scripts
and so this concludes the
last sort of uh you know part of my talk
about projects um and i wanted to
briefly walk through some future
directions and hopefully we can get some
more discussion going as well uh on that
i know that i think i have about 15
minutes left
so um to recap like in this talk i
talked about racial bias and hate speech
detection and proposed race-aware
annotation strategies to maybe mitigate
this um then i talked about social bias
frames as a new way of even viewing the
problem of hate speech detection by
looking at the bias and harmful
implications of language instead
and then finally i showed with power
transformer that we can revise and
devise text through the lens of
connotation frames
but there's a lot more to be done
towards this sort of broader goal of
avoiding and mitigating biases in
language with more human-centric models
and so i'm really excited about
furthering this research on
understanding how social biases show up
in human written language
so this requires looking at um how we
can do better at detecting social biases
and toxicity and language um so i'm
really excited about you know working
more on detect on developing formalisms
for contextual bias representation so
harking back to a question that was
there earlier
so for example you know a lot of these
representations have ignored the
conversational context in which things
appear
and actually the pragmatic implications
of uh conversation in terms of biases
are actually not trivial to capture
for example you could say something
really offensive and then someone else
could say oh i agree
um and then you know of course the first
utterance is offensive but then what do
you do about the second utterance like
knowing the stance towards offensive
utterances is also really important and
so we studied that a little bit in a
work called toxic chat um that was
published at emlp 2021.
um as i showed there's a lot of uh
differences in terms of like who the
speaker and listener and annotators are
when it comes to these kinds of um
sort of social biases and language and
so we need to keep looking at like how
those identities and the power dynamics
between those identities affect the
implications
um you know of course our social vice
very model wasn't perfect and so we need
better models to do better deeper
reasoning about biases and text
and as i mentioned i'm really excited
about this whole sort of application of
rewriting text to de-bias it and so
potentially using other dimensions than
the uh compensation frames of power and
agency but maybe using social bias
frames instead things like that
and you know this also requires studying
how humans would react to these kinds of
inputs from models like is someone going
to be more or less offended if a model
says that their
text might be biased versus a human
would say that
on the flip side i'm also really
interested and i think it's really
important to keep looking at how we can
avoid biases and toxicities in machine
generated language
um and so you know i've done some work
on scrutinizing the biases and toxicity
in these pre-trained language models
for example looking at you know how
quickly a language model could generate
toxicity but also
um how you know what about the
pre-training data and the way that
pre-training data was selected um
affects the types of biases and toxicity
that is in these machines
so for example in some recent work we
found that um i think that was published
at mlp 2021 as well we basically found
that like you know the african-american
english was really likely to be removed
from automatic sort of data quality
filters that google uses um for their
corpora so there's some problematic
things about that as well
also really excited about you know
finding ways to steer methods that are
um
that can help avoid toxicity and so this
is kind of also harkening back at the
earlier question of like what about the
pre-training data or the training data
versus like the
test time sort of behavior of models um
and like i said i think we should tackle
both and i'm really excited about
tackling both these things um so how can
we steer models that are already trained
and we may we know that they may have
toxic behavior how can we steer them
nonetheless to be less toxic
so we have some work called dexperts
where we basically
learn from the worst in a way where we
basically have a really really toxic lm
that is um an anti-role model for the uh
standard language model and so it's
basically like your really really racist
uncle and so if you know that your
racist uncle would say it then you know
that you shouldn't say it basically
um
you know and i think in terms of like
looking at steering these models and
avoiding toxicity and machine generated
texts like we should think about you
know
expanding what we should avoid and not
just avoiding swear words but also you
know maybe we want our models to be
pro-social and maybe we want them to not
violate social norms in general and just
follow community norms more um so
and specifically maybe we want you know
we want to allow for personalization so
that it's not just one culture that's
being represented in our machine
language our machine learning models
that um you know could be personalized
to your own culture and things like that
um and then finally i think there's i'm
really excited about bridging the gap
between nlp and social sciences in
general so um you know asking what
social sciences can do for improving nlp
systems so for example looking at how
psychology and social linguistics can
help us understand how people label or
perceive offensiveness and text
but also in general how can um cognitive
science uh sort of uh findings help us
understand how cognitive biases might
appear in cross-sourcing tasks in
general
and the converse of using nlp to answer
social science questions is also really
interesting so for example
you know we know that misinformation and
news is another big issue that's going
on
online where people are sharing this
information or propaganda
but can we make
machine learning or nlp systems that can
help us fight this by for example
distilling common tropes that are evoked
by headlines or um
producing or generating the sort of
likely reactions that someone would have
to a headline so that we know when
someone's really afraid that maybe we
should be careful about framing at
something it's framing something in a
very fear-mongering way
um and in general you know creating
methods for analyzing social phenomena
in text is also really important so that
we can answer social science questions
for that
all right that concludes my talk and i'm
really uh excited to have been able to
share my work with y'all and i want to
thank you all for listening um and i
specifically also want to thank my
collaborators because without them none
of this work that i just talked about
could have been possible and i'll take
more questions now
um i'll answer the questions so in
places where keyword censorship is
enforced i observe that people change
how they speak using code words or
acronyms to avoid censorship but
fundamentally it is not that effective
in actually preventing people from
talking about it basically detection is
of course more complicated and harder to
evade do you think that over time maybe
who will still find a way to avoid it
and rather the whole system uneffective
yeah absolutely and this is kind of a
dual use question too because like um
you know some moderation is really meant
to protect people for example there's
work from i think it's like sort of hci
people that looked at the um
pro-anorexia communities online um and
there's a constant battle of people that
are sort of trying to get people to
become more anorexic uh learning new
ways to promote the hashtags and things
like that and then the platforms and the
moderators like sort of falling behind
and just like trying to follow and like
being like okay this hashtag now means
this and things like that um so like in
the grand scheme of things it's like
well you know
shouldn't we moderate this and so it's
it's definitely a tricky question there
um
but
yeah i think if we can
if we could tackle at least like the if
we can set a rule around the biases that
we want to moderate like there's always
going to be people that are going to try
to evade it um
for sure yeah that's kind of yeah i
think that i don't actually know if
there's a good answer for this question
um but that's a really astute
observation for sure
um okay said something i'm curious
there's such a thing as kid friendly or
kid aware lm kids are spending record
time on devices online it's certainly a
governance issue but how do you
incorporate agents into the model to
make technology truly user-friendly
yeah that's hard because like who
decides what's appropriate for kids or
not right there's a anti-gay bill in
florida that's being trying to be pushed
where
people don't want to talk about
homosexuality um you know that's a very
political stance because like there are
kids that are gay and struggling with
that and so
um i
i just want to raise more questions
honestly because i'm not going to
pronounce myself only on that um
i don't know
that i think that
children protecting children is
oftentimes a reason that is used as an
excuse to uh justify censorship and
other things so i think we should be
careful about that kind of argument
though like are we actually looking at
what is actually harming children and
like what are the biases of those
studies versus
people just being morally outraged by
something and saying that their children
should be protected from it instead
so
it's not clear and also i think in
general we should be really regulating
the usage of ai and technology for
children because we do want to protect
them from things that's for sure
um
what techniques can be used to detect
social biases hate speech in languages
that we don't have large curated labeled
data sets for that's a really good
question
i don't know that
it's that possible um i think i mean you
know there's prob there's you know this
sort of
low resource language approaches that
people would use maybe multilingual
transfer type things could help
um
but like i think with these kinds of
things like i'm more interested in like
what the humans that are being affected
think and so we would need some sort of
information about what they like and
what they don't like in order to be able
to tackle these
um
you know undesirable language that
you're trying to
remove or you know
detect
i wonder if you've thought about some of
the potential risks
or ways in which this type of work could
be misused yeah so people talk about
dual use a lot in this case um so the
issue is that
like the cat is
pandora's box has been opened the
internet exists
and it's just rampant with hate speech
right now and it's pushing people out in
a lot of ways and so um not doing
anything about that problem is kind of
an implicit endorsement of the fact that
you know minority people are being
pushed out of these platforms or are
being silenced by these algorithms um so
like we don't really have a choice to
just go back to a world where this isn't
an issue and we can just pretend like it
doesn't exist anymore um i like to work
on making things a little bit better
because i think that people are you know
being censored and that's not wrong um
but like you know it's totally valid if
you would rather not work on it because
you're afraid that your technology's
gonna backfire you even more that's for
sure
um but i think like there's no good sort
of like we're already kind of in an
ethically uh that situation
unfortunately
so i've definitely thought about this a
lot
um
okay
have you
faced any opposition in applying your
research in toxicity detection yeah so
kind of uh same same question like i
think people get really freaked out that
they're gonna get censored um and it's
like the answer is that people are
already being censored maybe it's not
you
um but there's already people being
censored so like again cats out of the
bag like
you know
i don't think that it's like we're
developing technology that is just not
solving a real world problem and just
creating more problems like their you
know internet is already existing and so
social media exists and we should keep
working with legislators as well to like
prevent people from over
like from overstepping the power that
they they have
um so for example i think considering
social media platforms like not like you
know what a company can dictate
everything on but considering in like
public forums um and sort of having
regulations around like what kind of can
be said in public forums and looking at
those and seeing what um
what applies to social media platforms
is important
would you rather have checkers labelers
for offensive and effective text
incorporate be more or less
ideologically culturally congress what
metrics should we use to disqualify
someone from labeling text if any
yeah so
again that's where positionality of
researchers comes in like i didn't want
to create a data set that um
you know was all about flagging
anti-white
statements because that's not a
technology that i believe is
reflecting the actual harms that people
are experiencing
if a researcher wants to do that they're
free to you know i can't control what
they do
but um i think
yeah this is kind of a part where like
any technology that we develop comes
from a place of like our own biases and
our own positionality so um
we have to recognize that no matter what
we do right and it's not just because
we're tackling something that's um
politically charged all of a sudden that
um that's the only case is that these
kinds of positionality things affect our
research
and we have a live question
uh thank you for the talk it's really
enlightening i was wondering there's
always going to be a gap between
the values of the model builders and the
values of the people who are using these
models and
what do you think we can do in creating
some sort of system where
you know these values will constantly
evolve we're constantly changing what we
think is moral and not moral bias not
biased and you know these by these
values sort of evolved over like
thousands of years but now with ai
they're sort of evolving over minutes
and seconds like is there ways are there
ways to
sort of make sure we come up with a good
set of values but can adapt to kind of
the changing values of like you know
people who are using the models as well
yeah i mean
i think like ultimately like our
approaches should be more human-centric
than they currently are um and like
looking at you know who the stakeholders
of this technology are and like we're
just really starting to scratch the
surface only of like
bridging that gap between like
the developers and like the the people
that are being affected by this and so
um
we need to keep doing work just like
uncovering that link and like how people
are being affected and like looking at
what those people want um and doing that
kind of like value sensitive design like
looking at like what the communities
that are actually going to be affected
by this technology
want out of it but
um
just like any technology like nothing
should be static and if the world
changes like we should be changing our
technology with it as well to adapt with
it and so
um
yeah it's kind of a non-answer
because it's like yeah we should just be
you know talking to people and asking
them and getting out of the just nlp
part of it and just really going to the
to the users and asking them like what
are they what are they experiencing
um okay so
asked how is agency and power
transformer actually quantif uh quantify
a character to be positive or negative
are these based on actions and emotional
strength of characters being portrayed
so it's about the um the verbs that are
being used to describe these characters
so that's how we measure the agency of a
character basically so like are they
doing a lot of chewing or are they doing
a lot of sleeping basically
to simplify
um and there's you know it's just the
lexicon so um you can download the
lexicon and look at it as well um
in all the current social media
platforms images also play a crucial
role more like combination of image and
text very important for detecting heats
feature other biases do plant export yes
yeah i'm really excited i'm actually a
meeting with some open ai folks um
next week to talk about multimodal sort
of like toxicity detection and things
like that
um you know that's a whole other ball
game um unfortunately i my training
isn't just language so i don't really
have a lot of expertise in vision but
i'm really excited to try
seeing how that works um there's still a
lot of places where it's just text only
though so um i'm confident that i'll
still have some work to do
just in that
um
thank you for amazing sharing my
question is how to keep social bias
models we've talked about this lecture
updated to the social okay so that's
kind of what someone else asked as well
um just you know i think
that's the answer we just need to keep
updating things and just you know not
think of models as static and if we can
make our models be able to be
conditioned upon a large set of uh rules
or things that we know are problematic
or
and we can update that then our model
can apparently
uh be updated just by having the new
data accessible
so we have gone to 445 martin okay it's
up to you if you're if you're just
powering through and we're asking
answers
you're welcome too but you're also
welcome to take a deep sigh and stop
i feel like i'm just like i want to
answer everyone's questions because
they're also good
but um i should probably stop here just
in the interest of time and being
respectful of everyone who can't listen
to all the other questions
um but this was great i'm really excited
about all the questions that we got i
it's been a minute since i've been like
you know interrupted in the middle of
talks for questions so i wanted to
answer all of them
and try to get through everything but
this is awesome yeah well thank you so
much for
um giving this talk and your rich
insights into the area
yeah of course